donc
on
ans
[Musique]
on
oui donc bonjour à tous donc je remet
ainsi en tout cas tous ceux qui sont là
et qui sont arrivés à l'heure nous avons
nous attendons à encore d'autres jeunes
et d'autre part un qui ne sont pas
encore là les efforts pour être présent
à l'heure nous allons ensuite des bars
et si le grand jour ce matin douze
jeunes chefs d'entreprise ont formalisé
leur parrainage au cours de ce rendez
vous qui se tient à la mission locale
nord martinique du robert ces douze
créateurs vont nous ont plu à la
découverte de leur activité ce que je
voudrais dire aujourd'hui au gel
la tâche ne fait que commencer parce que
l entrepreneur est chef et patron ce
n'est pas une mince affaire
je vous souhaite beaucoup de courage et
je vous souhaite aussi chers patrons que
votre société prospère pour pouvoir
éventuellement trouver le temps
nécessaire pour que vous ayez la passion
et la patience des lots jeunes je vous
remercie et bonne journée à tous
[Musique]
célia est la première des douze jeunes
créateurs à qui nous rendons visite
directement après son master de génie
civil la jeune femme a créé une société
de construction
épaulé par son père je me suis dit baye
sympa et que j'apprends en étant jeune
et si après ça me plait pas bien je
pourrai toujours après trois parties ou
alors l'entreprise
c'est quoi une difficulté aujourd'hui
ici on marque pour les jeunes qui
cherchent à trouver du travail en fait
il ya de la demande
mais il cherche toujours des gens qui
ont de l'expérience deux ans trois ans
auquel on sort du banc de l'école qu'on
n'a pas cette expérience et c'est ce qui
manque en martinique on va dire la
formation pour les jeunes accepté de
l'eau fait confiance dès leur sortie
d'école quand ils ont déjà effectué
divers stages
donc techniquement ils sont aptes à
pouvoir tenir et poster directement
après les études on veut dire que il ya
un beau coup d'opprobre sur la jeunesse
qui s'offre enfin ils sont pas sont pas
tous un peu fou fou mais c'est yat que
c'est pas quelque chose qui fait qu'ils
nous fassent être confiance dans les
jeunes mais pourtant on a une jeunesse
martiniquaise très active et faut leur
laisser une chance et j'en connais
beaucoup de jeunes qui ont les capacités
nécessaires et kilomètres chaque jour
aux autres qu'ils qu'ils ont fait
confiance on m'a dit j'ai eu la liste
qui est allé sur place s'il m'a dit
ouais j'ai vu une jeune femme avec son
chapeau pas quoi son grand chapeau bas
croix et puis commencer à travailler
voilà il ya de quoi être fier donc la
cia tu te présentes ou plaisantant
d'entreprise bonjour à tous qu'il ya des
vices gérant de l'entreprise kazim qui
est une entreprise de gros oeuvre
charpente couverture en ce moment je
suis sur trois chantiers de trois villas
et ce qui m'a permise
aujourd'hui d'ouvrir ma société c'est
par rapport à mon parrain qui mon père
qui lui était chef d'entreprise
justement dans le btp pendant
une dizaine d'années et c'est un honneur
pour moi aujourd'hui qu'ils puissent
venir m'aider dans mon entreprise on
voit papa alors qu'il y avait un doute
parce que tant qu'il attendait un garçon
mais il a une fille la fille fonctionne
encore mieux qu'un garçon quand je lui
ai dit que je voulais faire du métier
pays les thèmes à d'abord demandé si
c'était mon choix parce que ils
voulaient docteur et voulait que sa
fille soit adopté avant tout avocat
du coup ils étaient étonnés de voir que
j'ai suivi ce second coup là mais
aujourd'hui ma compagne donc ça va le
parrain je crois qu'on est fiers parce
que je regardais pendant que s'il ya
parlait le nez gonflé gonflé gonflé et
bonjour à tous je suis champion 2010
donc ce n'est pas une machine au départ
en réalité est là faire bac s
et puis après elle avait choisi
bâtiment l'aéronautique le bâtiment est
arrivé avant donc je lui ai posé la
question est-ce que des youyous de
femmes ont choisi oui le faire et puis
après il ya eu un stage comme quand elle
est en bts
il y avait un stage à châteauneuf h
heure de l'est menacées dans le safe les
chantiers et puis à paulista je lui
demandais alors est-ce que ça n'a plus
bas oui c'est bien la vie on me dit les
gars donnent des blagues et tout ça me
fait rigoler du coup j'ai aussi de la
galabru goût et puis comme on l'a dit
souvent il faut donner aux jeunes il
faut se lancer il faut être motivé et
puis faut aller chercher son plaisent
vous mouiller sa chemise
si l'investisseur est l'atout de faire
et moi aussi si tout donne un avantage
félicitations et félicitations à notre
chef d'entreprise fait des citations à
son pari félicitations aux parents
parce que nous avons tendance à oublier
que pour arriver à ce stade c'est parce
qu'il y a une famille derrière et ça je
tiens le dire alors je voudrais vous
dire d'avoir recours à elle beaucoup de
courage pense que mener à bien vos
chantiers là puisque c'est un début
mener à bien vos chantiers
c'est presque la vitrine de la
martinique
la vitrine du chef d'entreprise pensent
que souvent à ce poste-là on ne trouve
justement pas de femmes
alors félicitations bonne continuation
et je pense que bientôt vous nous direz
que vous avez dit chantier
merci beaucoup
à montréal voici ses liens avec d'autres
jeunes créateurs d'entreprise
martiniquais pour suivre une formation
de leadership ce stage intensif d'une
semaine organisé par la mission locale a
pour objectif de donner assurance et
confiance en soi
[Musique]
vingt premiers homo arrivée au canada
mais l'impression de la formation c'est
qu'elles sont enrichissantes
on apprend beaucoup en plus les
intervenants viennent de différents
milieux qui ont rencontré divers
problématique de leur vie et ça touche à
peu près au fait toutes les cultures
[Musique]
championnats du monde je termine
deuxième joueuse le tableau l'orne à la
médaille great je me suis pas rendu
compte encore ça voulait dire quoi
exactement
deux heures plus tard les médailles soit
esstic jeune homme tel un peu comme ça
j'attends mon tour je suis assez je
m'allonge est à côté de moi
l'âge de 18 j'ai cru j'ai couru 9 84
anyway tout de suite un film qui passe
dans ma tête 17 ans le petit gars qui au
regard de la télévision qui regarde son
idole carlo est ce qu'il dit ouvertement
devant tout le monde
un problème un jour je vais le faire les
gens qui rient à lui
[Musique]
reportez votre médaille mais oui bien
sûr je met là je vais te la bête la
médaille d'or ouah donc je me suis
beaucoup vu dans son parcours notamment
la blessure qu'il a eue au ligament je
me suis dame ensevelie sous reagan
et quand j'ai vu que j'allais entendu ça
m'a fait beaucoup plaisir parce que je
me suis dit bon si lui l'a plus réussi à
il a pu faire autant de choses
moi qui pensais que tout serait terminé
je me suis dit mais je suis encore jeune
lui il est déjà âgé il a pu faire autant
de choses mais j'ai envie de faire
autant de choses et je me suis dit lui
l'arrêt si je vais réussir et c'est pour
ça notamment je lui ai demandé son
trophée pour me dire qu'à chaque fois
que je le verrai ce témoin non je me
dirais que lui m'a fait découvrir que je
peux y arriver avec la volonté et le
travail
les mercredis des jeunes la structure
périscolaire de célia grégoire ancienne
joueuse de football est née tout
simplement de son expérience personnelle
[Musique]
moi ma mère m'a toujours appris que pour
recevoir et kyodo
madame rêve et ainsi ne pas attendre
justement quand on donne et j'ai grandi
avec le foot quand j'étais jeune j'ai
fait l'école de foot
malheureusement quand je suis passé en
métropole avec la sélection en
martinique de football j'ai été blessé
au genou donc j'avais estimé que ma
carrière de foot était terminée j'avais
les ligaments et le ménisque endommagés
et quand je suis retourné en martinique
je suis retourné dans la résidence où
j'avais grandi et quand j'ai vu comment
c'est de çà avait changé en fait j'avais
des jeunes qui ont l'âge de ma nièce
nova qui récupère est des mégots de
cigarettes des mégots partout dans chez
eux chez leur mère obtient d'heure et se
réunissent et derrière le bâtiment et
commencer à fumer
donc moi j'ai pris l'initiative une
semaine que tous les jours j'allais
passer l'après-midi et le soir avec eux
[Musique]
quand nous avons fait les demandes pour
le local auprès d'eux adam on nous a dit
que il faut que ce soit une structure
pour qu'on puisse avoir les clés afin de
signer une convention
donc on n'a pas perdu de temps mon
équipe et moi on a tout de suite
commencé à crier les papiers dès que
j'ai eu une réponse est d tout est parti
de là on a commencé à faire des
activités avec eux les recevoir à faire
des recherches afin de trouver des
professeurs bénévoles parce que nous
sommes pas connus à l'animation pour les
jeunes ont fait on a commencé avec
l'animation mais notre but c'est
vraiment de d'effacer les lacunes
scolaires
célia a été encore plus loin que le seul
accompagnement scolaire grâce à la
formation leadership dispensés au canada
elle a pu rentrer en contact avec des
professionnels de la santé pour soigner
des jeunes martiniquais dyslexiques ans
à la mission locale
mais j'ai pu beaucoup évolué j'ai 20 ans
et ma structure et bientôt je l'espère
bien sera bien mis en place et qui
pourra également créer des emplois mon
but c'est de créer des emplois pour
aider les jeunes que j'ai dans ma
commune mais également autre part mais
également aider mes jeunes pour leur
montrer qu'ils ont un soutien comme moi
j'ai pu la voir dans mon passé
[Musique]
vraiment applaudir
c'est la consigne ans et voilà c'est
hyper activement ce mec qui a des idées
et des beaudottes et c'est très bien que
vous gardiez les contacts comme ça parce
que sur la formation canada y avait
encore une quinzaine d'intervenants et
des intervenants de qualité que je boive
m je n'aurais jamais pu réunir à la
mission locale donc cet apollon et non
négligeable pour vous aujourd'hui vous
en avez besoin
je crois que c'est important pour nous
de vous offrir ces clés là pour pour la
réussite voilà
[Musique]
et
on va plonger dans l'univers dans lequel
vous allez nous amener vous allez me
raconter quelque chose mais nous allons
fermer les yeux défendu de vous endormir
par contre défendu de toute façon ces
liens ne risque pas de nous de nous
endormir
non alors on ferme les yeux et on écoute
on reçoit bien ce que célia nous
raconter célia c'est un bon ce matin
lily rabe est un apport on me dit il il
est temps de se réveiller mais pour le
moment j'ai décidé
d'utiliser par mon entreprise tout ce
que j'ai vu dans la première partie de
la formation ce qui était le leadership
communicateur tout ce qui était aussi
management des employés comment gérer
les conflits réguliers et également la
prise de parole d'enfant groupe 2 au
monde où la construction devient de plus
en plus innovantes chaque jour une jeune
chef d'entreprise va et vient dans les
divers pays
on s'enrichit et l'adapter à ce pays
alors la formation canada n'est pas
indispensable c'est un plus que nous
apportons aux jeunes dans la mesure où
il nous faut convaincre les jeunes à
travers les témoignages pense que dans
cette formation nous avec nous avons
quelqu'un comme willy sur un qui
intervient il raconte son parcours et
les jeunes comprennent bien qu'on peut
sortir de très très belles très très
loin et on peut réussir
la réussite n'est pas réservé à une
élite à ceux qui y naissent avec la
cuillère d'argent dans la bouche mais
bien tout jeune à sa chance tout je ne
peux réussir à travers un projet de
création d'entreprise à travers une
activité ça peut être n'importe quelle
activité ça peut être de la peinture de
la culture mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
nous devons faire comprendre aux jeunes
que la réussite à leur portée et que
l'échec ne constitue qu'une étape vers
la réussite est souvent la réussite est
au bout
[Musique]
l'ensemble de ce dispositif mis en place
par la mission locale est destiné à la
création d'entreprise par les jeunes est
financé en partie par les fonds
européens dévolu à la martinique
la mission locale a répondu à un appel à
projet sollac 108 1 3 qui en direction
des jeunes
un appel à projets pour les 16 25 ans
pour les jeunes notamment ceux qui sont
situés ce le nord de la martinique
on est content parce que
souvent quand on parle des jeunes c'est
toujours vers la critique et là on a des
jeunes qui réussissent on a des jeunes
qui prouve qu'il y a de la matière grise
qui a marché passé avec eux on ne peut
être quatre fier de jouer
meurtri et c'est sur le terrain que
manuel césaire valérie en compagnie
locaux visitera trois nouvelle success
stories de jeunes créateurs au cours
d'un cycle découvertes les entreprises
ce matin on a voulu venir de visite et
donc à la mairie de trie mythique
elalamy le 7 mai qui devrait pas tarder
avec une élue et puis la ctm donc ce que
la 7e finance aussi le projet a aussi
financé en grande partie le projet avec
l'europe
donc tu vois je te laisser présenter ton
projet nous présenter ton entreprise
nous dire où tu en es comment ça
fonctionne
et puis surtout que de parler du soutien
des parents machin on en a parlé un
petit peu vous dire comme elle te pique
pouvoir faire fonctionner leurs doigts
brise il ya beaucoup de personnes
beaucoup de monde aux créances parce que
voilà beaucoup et que sur la martinique
il ya beaucoup de façons qui nous
visitent la main signe un cinquième la
martinique un peu une île paradisiaque
où d'accueil donc j'y reviens les gens
une voiture va visiter toute l'île si je
suis d'accord on était un petit peu
difficile et que c'est vrai que les
enfants sont un peu têtu lorsque les
parents pas du tout steven élève dans
une école d'architecturé dans l'hexagone
n'a pas réussi à obtenir une alternance
en entreprise
il est donc rentré au pays pour mûrir
son projet avec le soutien de la mission
locale
quand un jeune franchi la porte de la
mission locale ont la compagne de 1,7 à
l'écran par moments il veut crayon il a
commencé à y arriver on le prend bien en
amont moment il arrive il sait pas
encore ce qu'il veut faire
la compagnie travaille avec lui on
définir vos un professionnel et
lorsqu'on a travaillé le projet
fonctionnel d'après un autre type
d'accompagnement que cela replace sur la
tsr robuste que c'est à l'accompagnement
spécifique avec les conservations à deux
reprises et là le chemin continue et je
pense que c'est ce qui fait la réussite
d'un tel projet alors comme ces bleus
c'est que c'est disponible
les élections c'est conserver d'accord
quand tu as vécu dans l'émission
[Musique]
saint omer
roma
[Musique]
voilà je vois que tu dans un pool
carrément d'orthophonistes voilà je vous
inquiétez tout seul pour l'autre glisse
donc c'est très bien
la tempête en n'ayant plus beaucoup dans
votre liste je me suis rendu compte que
c'est un match et qui me passionnait et
que j'avais envie d'exercer
donc je suis parti en fait en belgique
pour faire mes études j'ai fait ma soeur
en d'orthophonie et je suis revenu ici
il ya à peine de lancer une consultation
28 eur donc pour le moment je suis en
collaboration à trinité et le but en
fait c'est de pouvoir monter moi même
jardin thérapeutique on me permettent
justement de travailler avec les adultes
et également les enfants dans un espace
qui soit plus un lorsqu'on a constaté
que tout ce qui est jardin thérapeutique
permettait d'améliorer la prise en
charge chez les enfants et chez les
adultes
donc pour le moment je suis en
collaboration mais j'espère en tout cas
créé ce jardin
merci
[Musique]
en
sophie
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
complet
pas sûr
présente nous répétons l'entreprise et
puis présentement après s'être fait
réaliser à la charpente extension une
entreprise qui fait majoritairement de
la charpente
comme dit le nom après amphis des
extensions on dit le no 6 on est amené à
dire du dès que des échos version du
faux-plafond même du placo moi j'ai fait
deux ans de notre prison après la france
et c'était une entreprise vous serez pas
dire de nom mais c'est une grosse boîte
qui tournait sauf que le patient cette
région très très dur ça bloquait y avait
des jeunes qui arrivent et je comme moi
et je sais j'y suis amené à travailler a
montré aucune reconnaissance aucun agent
et au final c'était like honey des
pyrénées je vais lui baissé comme tsonga
ce que tu es une jeunesse c'est comme ça
cette histoire de boîtes à chaque fois
car les le patron la pression est
toujours avoir une boîte on s'amuse où
s'écoule en travaillant sans m'en parler
sous le travail bien fait le travail est
satisfait tout le monde est satisfait
tout le monde est gagnant mais voilà ça
vous gagne tu as maté su réagir tant que
chef d'entreprise maintenant et tu
verras la tuque du rocher à l'autre ben
tout ce que je dis pas ce que je demande
la têt salariés des performants depuis
je pense aussi
[Musique]
alors
ce crime
bon
[Musique]
qu'un plus
les motivations des créateurs diffèrent
d'un jeune à l'autre melek votive reste
le même
vivre en martinique de leur profession
sarah est revenu au pays exercer son art
et elle prend son qui sous l'effet des
trois mois après tout dépend de si vous
n'êtes pas voir leur pouce au bout de
trois fois le remplissage tout a
commencé après l'obtention de mon bac
j'ai décidé de partir en france
j'ai passé mon cap esthétique sur un an
en alternance
ensuite j'ai commencé à travailler en
tant que responsable
au bout de deux ans et demi on va
malheureusement la chance d'être
licencié économiquement donc du coup
j'ai décidé de retourner chez ma mère
après une bonne réflexion je me suis dit
pourquoi pas être à mon compte
en gros même étant jeune on peut être
futur chef d'entreprise
donc ça peut être un exemple pour celles
qui ont l'idée et l'envié de les faire
du vélo aujourd'hui à nouveau aussi
sinon on a eu des touches larges
interdit il ya du travail et en
martinique 6 juste qu'il faut chercher
il ne pas comment dire rester là ils
disent qu'il n'ya pas très bien
renseignés donc on part en france non on
peut y arriver en martinique c'est juste
comment dirais je il faut de la
motivation et la détermination aussi et
surtout être sûr y voir
romuald a accepté que nous
l'accompagnons dans ses démarches
administratives de création
d'entreprises à commencer par celles à
la chambre de commerce de fort de france
11 jeunesse transport marchandises et ce
avant de commencer un petit club qui
font honneur comme ça des percées un
fumeur
les feux de la chambre de commerce
compte bien suivre des voies donc
l'activité sa bière l'activité de la
transporte donc je vais vous donner la
liste des pièces nécessaires pour la
création voulait faire dé sa nouvelle
société à responsabilité limitée en tant
qu il vous faudra coûtera donc c'est une
activité réglementée vous faudra aller à
la v1 d'abord avoir un certificat
d'immatriculation provisoire
les formalités de création ne sont pas
forcément compliqué donc il ya des
choses à respecter il ya un parcours ça
fait partie du parc au et je crois qu'il
est important que nos jeunes comprennent
bien qu'elle ait ce parcours et se dire
que ce parfum est nécessaire pour
l'enregistrement de l'activité pour la
déclaration et puis pour mettre aux
normes
une activité ici ça sert à rien de créer
une activité de ne pas la déclarer ou ou
de fonctionner je crois qu'une
entreprise ne fonctionne correctement
que lorsqu'elle sait respecter les
règles et lorsqu'elle s'est rentré dans
un cadre et nous apprenons aux jeunes
justement à travers cet accompagnement
avec les conseillers en création
d'entreprise nous leur apprenons à
respecter les règles et à mettre une
entreprise en place de manière pérenne
c'est à dire avec tous les atouts
nécessaires dès le démarrage du projet
ronald a réuni tous les documents
nécessaires pour immatriculer sa société
le parcours se termine immuablement par
le quotidien france antilles pour la
parution légal
la dernière étape vers une nouvelle et
belle aventure
vendredi dans un journal ou une assiette
quelques étapes à franchir et je pense
que ça sera bon pour la mer a servi par
monsieur rebonds
[Musique]
retour à la mission locale nord
en plus d'être accompagnés dans leur
démarche de création les jeunes chefs
d'entreprise sont formés en comptabilité
par exemple comme ce matin
[Musique]
oui
bon on va commencer toujours des
révisions de trucs qu'on a fait avant on
a vu comment quelqu'un ayant commencé
une facturation intitulé qu'est-ce que
vous avez pas compris à nos fausses ou
les exercices qu'on nous avons fait la
dernière fois
c'est exercer ça t'as pas compris
c'est l'exercice de facturations ont
entendu le taux de tva pour la boîte est
de 5,5 pour cent
à quoi est également montant de tva
c'est quoi la formule pour que je puisse
trouver mon moteur de tva non le prix
aux textes x qua non à quoi était d'un
montant de tva je veux juste la formule
mon manteau de tvn était d'aller à quoi
je veux pas de chiffres je veux une
formule le montant en tête plus montant
de tva on va bien au delà de ce week-end
est donc maintenant à quoi était dans le
momentum ttc dans le cas de cet appel à
projets avec la ctn nous avons souhaité
l'europe
nous avons souhaité mettre en place des
formations pour nos jeunes
au delà de la formation leadership ou
leur apprendre à devenir des vrais
leaders nous devions leur expliquer
comment ça fonctionne en termes de
facturation en termes d'organisation
comptable parce que une entreprise qui
organisait dès le début de ces notre
avis qui va réussir on le sait ça si je
décide de créer mon entreprise c'est
qu'elles soient les différents statuts
juridiques que je peux opter on va dire
et ça ça passe par la formation et nous
avons eu une très belle formation avec
l'entreprise jmj donc cette entreprise a
permis de le former nos jeunes justement
à une partie gestion une partie
marketing
voilà et c'est quand même très très
important parce que les jeunes sont
friands de cela ils ont besoin de savoir
ils ont soif de savoir
ils veulent savoir comment ça fonctionne
comment ça marche et c'est à nous de
leur donner deux pas de leur donner les
pistes
à nous de leur donner le savoir
justement pour qu'il réussisse et ce
n'est pas tout le concours des mini
entreprises organisé par le réseau
national entreprendre pour apprendre
favorise l'entreprenariat des jeunes
chaque année les créateurs de la mine
nord rivalisent d'inventivité dans les
projets toujours plus innovants au
programme de l'édition 2010 9,3 mini
entreprises donat assistance autour du
maintien à domicile des personnes âgées
grâce à la télésurveillance bambou move
la réalisation de couverts en bambou et
bio pas cannes et création de bouteilles
recyclables à partir de bagasse
[Musique]
alors le champion 2009 catégorie
initiative emploi et justement vient pas
d'un malaise il faut que ça rentre
cette cérémonie c'est vrai je suis
vraiment très très fier très fier de ses
jeunes parce que nous avons remporté
plusieurs prix donc donné à 6 ans a
remporté le prix du coup de coeur du
jury
nous avons aussi beau move qui a eu le
prix du plus beau stade
et puis nous avons plus paquin qui a eu
le prix de la meilleure stratégie
commerciale et puis en dernier lieu
le prix champion des champions de la
martinique dont le cadre d'initiatives
emploi c'est diop à kent qui va
représenter la martinique 1 lille au
mois de juillet
[Musique]
ce concours est un laboratoire pour
expérimenter le savoir-faire et
l'ingéniosité de jeunes entrepreneurs
marc ligny qu'est ce qui le concept
économique est retenu lors de la seconde
phase qui se déroulent cette année à
lille c'est le plus sûr moyen pour bio
pacanes de créer demain une vraie
société
mesdames et messieurs bonjour à l'infini
comme partout d'ailleurs comme vous
pouvez le constater le niveau
d'évolution mondiale ne cesse de croître
et là et le plastique n'a pas d'une
monoplace de cette pollution
c'est pourquoi en janvier 2020 une loi
visant à interdire l'utilisation du
plastique sera appliquée cependant le
plastique est utilisé dans notre
quotidien et il a donc fallu trouver une
alternative à celui ci cette alternative
peut être économiquement viable
la réponse est oui et c'est ce que nous
allons découvrir tout au long de cette
présentation biopic n est une mini
entreprise de quatre personnes elle a sa
tête
it is marketing accompagné d'un
administratif et comptable technique et
moi même elle a pour principale activité
la conception et la commercialisation de
contenants à base de bagasse
alors mesdames et messieurs tout au long
de cette présentation nous avons mis en
avant nos bouteilles nos produits
maintenant aussi à nous mettre en avant
quand il nous a fallu du temps de la
patience de la détermination du chaos
oui cette passion commune qui nous a
permis d'être ici présents devant vous
je patine ensemble
yes we can to give up on sent quand même
qu'on saigne à 300 en tout cas on espère
arriver quand même parmi les premiers
partis ou d'un point à pour arriver à un
point b il ya eu beaucoup de choses qui
se sont passées entre-temps on a dû
faire beaucoup de sacrifices et on s'est
découvert et on s'est découvert de
nouvelles capacités
c'est vraiment incroyable de voir à quel
point on peut se dépasser lorsqu on a
vraiment envie de réussir et la passion
pour notre projet de 764 euros soit 205
alors les répétitions se sont bien
passées silva que nos jeunes ont
bénéficié des conseils des personnes
comme à la mettrait le monsieur pépy qui
ont déjà qu'ils connaissent très bien
son concours
donc nos jeunes ont démontré ont montré
ce qu'ils allaient présenter ce matin et
ils ont eu la chance mais je n'ai que
c'est une chance parce qu'ils ont eu des
avis ou des remarques sur la posture sur
la manière de présenter leur projet de
mettre en valeur le projet et je crois
que c'est une très très bonne chose et
j'espère faire un pays ce matin que ces
jeunes y mettrons en pratique ce qu'ils
ont appris ce qu'ils ont vu pour bien
valorisé ce projet bio paquin mesdames
et messieurs bonjour en martinique comme
partout ailleurs comme vous pouvez le
constater le niveau de pollution
mondiale ne cesse de croître et le
plastique n'a pas eu moins de place à
cette pollution
cependant en janvier 2020 une loi visant
à interdire l'utilisation du plastique
sera appliquée le plastique est utilisé
dans notre quotidien et il a donc fallu
trouver une alternative à celui ci cette
alternative peut-elle être
économiquement viable
la réponse est oui et c'est ce que nous
allons découvrir tout au long de cette
présentation
alors la bagasse qu'est ce que c'est la
bagasse est le résidu finale de la canne
à sucre
après extraction du jus se produit que
nous vous présentons aujourd'hui est un
produit 100% recyclable et biodégradable
tout un système d'économie circulaire
gravitent autour de celui ci car de sa
plantation jusqu'à la dégradation la
canne à sucre est utilisé tout au long
de son cycle de vie
aujourd'hui notre mini entreprise bio
paquin commercialise des bouteilles
issues de lusine lice packaging mais
elle conçoit également des pots de
yaourt des pots à fleurs des verrines
ainsi que des bouteilles nous proposons
donc nos bouteilles au chi de 80
centimes
nos autres contenants mon truc différent
des panneaux des spécificités les
commandes
sa durée de vie est estimée à environ
huit mois selon l'environnement en tant
que demi grossistes nous adressons une
clientèle professionnelle en majorité du
pack m yes we can't get
c'est vrai qu'on attendait ce moment là
donc les jeunes étaient un petit peu
stressé ça se comprend c'est normal on
passe devant jury jury à ses nombreux
parce qu'on courait pour différentes
thématiques donc la présentation était
très bien sauf que dans les réponses aux
questions
les jeunes ont un petit peu péché c'est
un petit peu dommage parce que ça
diminue et la prestation un petit peu
parce qu'en fait on leur a posé des
questions du style bon le produit la
bouteille et en bagasse mais le bouchon
et comment est-ce que sensible m'agace
aussi un jeune qui répond non sans
placer alors qu'on me dit qu'on va faire
un produit qui est censé remplacer le
plastique
donc on ne peut pas répondre cela et
puis les questions sur la rentabilité
les jeunes un petit peu pêché un petit
peu hésité sur les commandos si c'est
encore un petit peu hésitant c'est
dommage voilà
à présent vous à vos micros
vous allez remettre le prix de vice
champion de france en catégorie collège
c'est bien ça alors il s'agit de la
milliers d'entreprises happy days
[Musique]
bien la vie des entreprises les échos
créatif de saint-andré la réunion le
prix qui leur est attribué à
l'entreprise
brasles la concurrence est rude entre
les mini-entreprises cette année et les
projets tous de haut niveau la mission
locale nord martinique ne rapportera pas
de prix de l'île mais la société bio
pacanes pourra certainement de beaux
jours devant elle même si nous n'avons
pas gagné c'est vrai mais nous sommes
partis va nous allons repartir plus
forte et nous avons obtenu beaucoup de
leçons de cette expérience que nous
voulons par la suite mettre en place de
notre entreprise
quand on regarde un peu les autres
crimes ayant compris ce qu'ils ont gagné
on a réalisé vraiment que il vivait
pleinement ce qu'ils disent est en fait
nous on avait mis un peu plus de coeur
et -2 de commander 2
rigidité tous n'avaient plus librement
comme on avait fait la première formule
unique
c'est vrai que ça a été ça aurait changé
beaucoup de choses
bioparc ensemble yes we came to be over
et
nous sommes partis en viol depuis le
ponton du robert retrouver un autre
jeune entrepreneur sur une plateforme
aquacole
norman diplômé d'un master de commerce
cette gestion se lance dans la
transformation du poisson tels que le
new des caraïbes en d'armes ou rillettes
[Musique]
les loups sont bien là mais
remanié pas il semble que la pêche aux
voix des jeunes fini norman a rejoint la
berge
mon activité c'est de la transformation
de produits de la mer donc on récupère
un bon poisson et des fruits de mer
auprès des pêcheurs et des agriculteurs
de la martinique ou qu'on puisse les
transformer en filets d'un cette équipe
avec poisson on va faire aussi du
poisson fumé dans le nouveau local
ils sont revendus en majorité aux
restaurateurs et d'autre part aux
particuliers le but c'est serait
d'arriver à faire des produits un peu
plus transformé avec une transformation
pour lui finie c'est à dire des
vignettes des beurs de poissons et
d'autres mais bon ça c'est par la suite
ça va venir avec un peu dès que
l'entreprise sera un peu plus installée
parce que ça demande encore des
investissements un peu plus cher donc
oui c'est là c'est le but premier
mais on y arrive on y arrive ça va
demander un peu de temps de
l'investissement et du scra vice et
c'est comme ça c'est j'avais une
entreprise c'est comme ça moi pour
commercialiser le poisson j'ai une
dérogation sanitaire mais je peux vendre
consommateur final les prêts sont vides
et il faut faire confiance aux jeunes
parce que ces jeunes là où représente
notre futur c'est eux qui devront
assurer la relève
parce que souvent j'entends des jeunes
dit ouais mais monsieur les adultes ne
nous font pas confiance
donc lorsqu'on leur fait pas confiance
en eux mêmes n'ont plus confiance en eux
ce qui est important c'est de faire
comprendre aux jeunes qu'il a sa propre
valeur ajoutée il est nous avons
différents il est de la génération
facebook il est dans la génération
instagram c'est vrai que c'est différent
il ya des modèles de communication qui
ne sont pas les mêmes il ya un mode de
fonctionnement qui n'est pas le même
mais l'objet reste toujours le même
c'est comment on arrive à créer une
continuité dans la société et cette
jeunesse là est censé assurer la
et nous devons la préparer pour assurer
cette relève le vrai travail
c'est la réflexion du jeune martiniquais
du martiniquais tokyo qui va tout faire
ou que ce territoire soit une réussite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois que la première première chose
dont il faut se préoccuper c'est d'avoir
une vision d'avoir une perspective
qu'est-ce qu'on poursuit au sein de
notre organisation au sein de
l'institution dans laquelle on se trouve
qu'est-ce qu'on veut atteindre comment
voit-on l'avenir quand on est chef de sa
propre entreprise ou qu'on veut être un
entrepreneur
ça veut dire avoir des objectifs clairs
d'avoir une perspective
et bien sûr ça doit s'appuyer sur
certaines convictions
c'est là qu'on touche la question des
valeurs parce que si ce n'est pas le cas
ça sera toujours artificielle et ce qui
est artificiel finit toujours par ses
flûtes et donc il faut vraiment
s'appuyer sur des convictions par
exemple moi quand je suis devenu chef du
parti québécois parce que j'ai été chef
du parti québécois avant d'être première
minute c'est ce qui m'a amené à être
première menée du québec
j'avais une vision pour le québec que je
voulais un québec plus riches un québec
plus vers un québec plus égalitaire en
québec d'égalité des chances donc
seulement que les hommes et les femmes
mais entre les différents citoyens
j'ai vraiment apprécié la force et le
courage de tous les formateurs et de
tous les intervenants que nous avons pu
rencontrer à montréal quand ce sont des
personnes qui n'ont pas lâché leur
objectif ils ont vraiment suivi le but
qu'ils avaient ils ont accompli vraiment
de grandes choses même s'il y avait des
difficultés que ces terrains donc je
sais que je serai amené
rencontre également des difficultés mais
je compte vraiment qu'on ne rien lâcher
pouvoir continuer sur cette lancée
[Musique]
je suis en phase de création
d'entreprise je compte ouvrir
prochainement j'espère bien sûr ce
serait une entreprise de location de
véhicules et d'engins de chantier
dès son retour en martinique samantha
immatriculent à sa structure pour son
plus grand plaisir
est ce que c'est un plaisir de la paix
une entreprise c'est une notion de
plaisir but à atteindre et chaque étape
chaque petite bonne nouvelle c'est
c'est un petit accomplissement après il
faut être fort avoir du mental
bon il ya pour certaines personnes ça va
c'est quelque chose de simple ils ont
toutes les cartes dans leurs mains mais
il y à d'autres il faut s'armer de
patience et il faut avoir un mental
d'acier et samantha fait le choix de
créer son entreprise en martinique pour
s'assurer un emploi et consolider son
avenir face au manque de perspectives de
travail
la jeune femme aurait pu tout aussi bien
quitter l'île ce qui se passe c'est que
malheureusement il ya une fuite des
cerveaux et je ne préfère partir
ailleurs travailler ou faire leurs
études
si je n'avais aucune attache et
alors il fait la même chose qui est
alors là attention grâce pour la race et
si c'est bon natanaël est un photographe
très prisé dans le milieu de la mode
lors de ce shooting parisien l'artiste
martiniquais met en valeur des
blogueuses d'origine antillaise
la passion est souvent le début d'une
carrière prometteuse
comme tu faisais comme tu le regardes et
voilà
le plus con chez la photographie fait la
photographie depuis six ans dès l'âge de
14 ans cette passion m'est venue par
rapport à la nature le rapport aux
couleurs tout ce qui nous entoure et
j'ai commencé par la maco graphie
d'après mcafee c'est quoi la
mammographie c'est mettre un sujet de
petite taille
en gros plan donc mettre en valeur de
coup par la suite j'ai fait la photo de
mode et la martinique mais je fais des
allers retours donc du coup ce sont la
martinique angers de demandes sur paris
ben je vais son pari donc voilà le monde
m'appartenait
têtes épargnées t'asseoir mais de toute
façon
super
mettant le visage un peu super
moustoir est ce que tu es
magnifique ben je dirais un jeune
martiniquais en fait de croire en ses
rêves d'avancer et de pas lâcher n'ont
rien lâché donc on nous a demandé de
rajouter une couverture histoire de
protéger les éléments à l'intérieur
donc on a choisi de réaliser une toiture
en neuf ans pour réaliser réaliser des
travaux
donc ça c'est un premier travail qu'on a
effectué ici pour eux ou leviers qui
nous présente aujourd'hui l'une de ses
réalisations a créé quant à lui une
entreprise de construction en bois
il a été fortement épaulée par son père
qui lui a transmis clients et savoir
faire
alors moi j'ai mon père qui a toujours
été charpentier et donc du coup j'ai ben
dans le métier depuis depuis tout petit
quand j'étais encore au lycée je vais le
travailler j'avais eu la passion est
venue comme ça et puis j'ai décidé de
lancer mon entreprise - de suivre le
suivre ses traces et du coup ils
m'aident pour m aujourd'hui puisqu'il a
social coin dans la société et puis
j'essaie de faire aussi bien sinon mieux
que ce que lui l'a fait en place et on
l'a réalisé le kiosque en dupant parce
qu'en fait on a réalisé ce qui aux
poulets pour les employés parce que
impose de entre midi et deux quand ils
ont leur pause ils ont besoin de venir
se détendre décompresser manger donc on
a réalisé ce kiosque larmes
[Musique]
c'est que le début c'est que début juin
d'immatriculer ma société donc aussi
reprendre le début c'est difficile de
trouver du travail de ce fait rôle non
heureusement grâce à mon père qui a déjà
son portefeuille clients saas sa dîme
assez bien
mais pour l'instant je suis je suis
plutôt fier après c'est vrai qu'à des
difficultés mais on essaie de se motiver
pas c'est pas tous les jours facile des
fois on a envie de laisser tomber mais
jamais motivé au maximum pour arriver à
man
[Musique]
cette transmission se concrétise par la
signature d'un contrat de parrainage
entre les jeunes entrepreneurs et leur
mentor à la mission locale
ici tout est mis en oeuvre pour que les
jeunes entrepreneurs réussissent dans
partant soutien formation accompagnement
conseil de l'ue d'entre eux ont déjà
immatriculés leur société d'autres sont
sur le point de le faire
mais au delà des chiffres il ya de
l'espoir l'espoir d'une jeunesse qui
peut enfin réaliser ses rêves
professionnels créer son propre emploi
et ceux d'autres jeunes demain
nous sommes très fiers très heureux très
contents de voir que les jeunes à partir
du moment en loques temps là mais à
partir du moment où on leur présente la
route et le chemin à suivre
nous jeunes s'engagent et sont
différents
on dit souvent oui ils n'ont pas envie
de son fait new york mais dont deux lors
la main donnons leur la main et nous
verrons bien s'ils sont fainéants aussi
l'ont pas envie et je crois que beaucoup
seraient étonnés de voir l'attitude des
jeunes de voir comment le jeune bassiste
à nous de leur donner la main à nous de
l'homme
envie à nous leurrer culte et les vraies
valeurs vraies valeurs du travail et
nous sommes tous engagés nous sommes
tous responsables de l'avenir de nos
enfants
[Musique]
e
à